ich bin jetzt quasi in dieser spinne
drin und kann jetzt die nicht steuern
aber ich kann genau sehen was die spinne
gezählt sieht die bewegte bewegt sich
gerade irgendwie gar nicht aber es ist
richtig richtig krank ich mal guckt euch
an so guckt eine spinne quasi michael
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft facts heute mit einer
kleinen special sache und zwar wenn ich
noch extra nehmen über die minecraft 1.8
di am zweiten september raus kommt also
in circa einer woche
man kann jetzt kommen wahrscheinlich
wieder ein paar leute an und malen
das sind ja nur neuerungen die duh
vorstellt ist in der kein effekt ich
habe versucht mir nicht auf die
neuerungen zu spezialisieren sondern ich
habe geguckt okay was ist dazu gekommen
und von den sachen die hinzugekommen
sind was ist daran so quasi besonders
also was kann man da ran an den fag
quasi vorstellen und dann würde ich
sagen fahren wir direkt an mit dem
ersten takt und zwar dörfer gibt es ja
schon sehr sehr lange in minecraft
allerdings ist diese generierung immer
so ein bisschen komisch gewesen das
heißt dass stürzen manchmal blöcke 1 und
vor allem in die an irgendwelchen bergen
sind oder so ob es ruckelt ein bisschen
aber ist eine primiz in der stadt spiele
und immer wenn ihr irgendwelche bergen
sind oder so dann stürzen die manchmal
ein und diese wege krachen ein weil die
sind ja aus greven und alles mögliche da
wurde allerdings hinzugefügt dass unter
den griffel sachen es ruckelt wirklich
noch ein bisschen tut mir ein bisschen
leid weiter hat ein privates wir sehen
unter diesen gremmel sachen ist entweder
noch mal traveled runter oder es ist
einfach direkt stein drunter wir können
sich auch nochmal sehen wir
beispielsweise mich einfach mal gucken
da ist einfach cobblestone darunter
einfach um diesen gremmel quasi zu
halten das heißt auch wenn dörfer
generiert werden irgendwie in
irgendwelchen bergigen region oder so
dass da immer irgendwie cobblestone
drunter ist damit diese ganze sache
nicht runterfallen das heißt
beispielsweise wenn ich jetzt hier
einfach mal runter short-squeeze
darunter des kopisten drunter des kombis
darunter dass kommissar und runter das
controller unter dem kommission ist dann
erst werde die normale welt das ist
eigentlich eine ganz ganz geile sache
und ein ganz ganz cool effect damit
einfach diese ganzen bilde die ganzen
dörfer quasi nicht einfach einstürzen
wenn die ganzen sachen der generiert
werden sondern dass das ganze endlich
mal normal ebene bleibt und das ist eine
sache die auf jeden fall hinzugefügt
wurde und sehr sehr cool ist perfekt
nummer zwei und zwar wird ja schon vor
einiger zeit diese welt barriere
hinzugefügt welche an diesen koordinaten
ich zeig euch mal ganz kurz durch f3 an
der stelle 30 millionen beziehungsweise
kurz vor 30 millionen wird quasi diese
welt mauer generiert dieser welt
barriere und die zeigt dann quasi an
dass sie die welt vorbei ist was
allerdings ein 1.8 dazu gekommen ist
dass dahinter nichts mehr generiert wird
also ihr seht da vorne wenn man da mal
hinguckt das sind keine anderen blöcke
mehr generiert da sind hier nur noch
irgendwie so zehn stück generiert und
danach gar nix mehr
und was auch hinzugefügt wurde dass man
da keine tiere mehr rein schubsen kann
keine blöcke ersetzen kann das heißt
wenn ich einen blog nehme ich drücke
rechtsklick kann ich da nicht hinsetzen
erst wieder wenn ich hier stehe so und
auch wenn ich ein tier nehme
beispielsweise in shah verschaffen will
kann ich da auch ein externer das ist
ganz egal das ding geht der zehn jahre
lang hoch das hätte da schon und auch
ich kann da auch nichts rein drücken
also wenn ich hier gegen das schaf gegen
lauf und das versuche daran zu drücken
passierte auch nix hier ich drückt
dagegen blablabla es passiert nichts
also die welt barriere hat jetzt eine
kleine animation hierdurch bekommen wie
quasi diese world model kennt sie ja
durch minecraft captain bei auf seiner
world order und man kann mit ihnen die
ganze welt bzw
dahinter keine mops reinen spawn und man
kann da keine blöcke hinsetzen und es
ist wirklich eine wichtige barriere so
normalerweise würde jetzt um den dreh
irgendwann so das geheimnisvolle
geräusche kommen wo ich jetzt irgendwas
nehme dann mache ich irgendein geräusch
und sagte kent in die kommentare
schreiben
er wollte eventuell werde in der
nächsten folge erwähnt wird ein
kommentar allerdings in der letzten
folge meinten sehr viele leute höhe was
bringt das überhaupt das macht ja keinen
sinn mit dem geheimnisvollen geräusch
das hier sind minecraft fakes und keine
geheimnisvolle geräusche folgen oder
irgendwie so hasst deswegen wollte ich
das ganze jetzt noch einmal kurz vor
lesen und zwar das letzte geräusch ein
loch ha und das hat anna t punkt richtig
erraten sind wir gerade eingeblendet und
da sehr viele das ganze in frage
gestellt haben rum gemeckert haben habe
ich mir gedacht ich mach einfach mal
eine umfrage wo ihr anonym sagen könnt
hey ich finde es gut mit dem
geheimnisvollen geräusch ist uns macht
ist eine coole sache macht das bitte
weiter oder sie eigentlich wenig das
vollblut firma auf damit
und da könnt ihr ganz anonym abstimmen
und in der beschreibung findet ihr einen
link in den ersten drei zeilen glaube
irgendwann da steht dann umfrage doppel
punkten kann einfach draufklicken an
dafür abstimmen ob ihr das weiterhin
haben wollt oder nicht und dann werde
ich mich dementsprechend nachrichten
jetzt gehts weiter mit dem vers so
freunde der nächste feld wurde mir
zugesendet von
markus oder tobias also die mailadresse
heißt markus aber eher runter
geschrieben viele grüße tobias also
markus oder tobias danke für den effekt
und zwar wurde ja schon damals einen
game mode drei hinzugefügt
beziehungsweise jetzt in dieser version
und über diesen game mode können wir
quasi zum geist werden durch blöcke
durchfliegen durch höhlen durchfliegen
und alles mögliche quasi in der welt
machen und ich hab ich schon so ein paar
mopar in der hand und ihr werdet auch
sehen was man damit mich noch machen
kann ich es schaffe ich jetzt erstmal in
fährt dann macht ihr beispielsweise mal
eine spinne hin dann mal silberfisch und
hier noch einen guardian beispielsweise
maximal kurz alle weg zeigt euch mal
ganz kurz den gamer 3 so sieht das ganze
auch hier sind wir quasi jetzt ein geist
können hiermit durch blöcke durch
fliegen kann uns alles möglich angucken
könnt ihr selber testen und das aller
krasseste wir können links klicks
linksklick auf tiere machen und
beispielsweise kann ich jetzt durch die
augen von einer spinne sehen
ich bin jetzt quasi in dieser spinne
drin und kann jetzt die nicht steuern
aber ich kann genau sehen was die spinne
gesät sieht die bewegt bewegt sich
gerade irgendwie gar nicht aber es ist
richtig richtig krank ich mich an so
guckt eine spinne quasi minecraft wenn
ich jetzt schiff wieder drücke seht ihr
dass ich da wieder raus kann das ganze
kann ich jetzt auch bei einem pferd
machen einfach mal so schaut das pferd
gerade ist es relativ unspektakulär hier
der silberfisch so sieht der silberfisch
das kann alles irgendwie bewegen die
sich alle nichts ist ein bisschen
komisch und der guardian wussten der
guardian hin guardian derartigen soll
jetzt bin ich hier beim guardian der
bewegt sich endlich mal so ich habe hier
meine hände
ihr seht ich bewege mich nicht aber der
goalie bewegt sich jetzt schaut er sich
gerade eine art noch an
und jetzt fokussiert in den tintenfisch
und greift ihn wahrscheinlich jetzt an
ja es hat er den tintenfisch angegriffen
also das ist richtig cool man ist quasi
so in den mops drin und da seht ihr die
world oder kommt er nicht durch die
world oder durch ich gehe hier mal
wieder raus
mal schauen ich finde ein bisschen
traurig dass ich die spinne da nicht
bewegt druck ist wieder ein bisschen
doch so ein bisschen bewegt sich also
das ist richtig krank vor allem einer
spinne ist das so mega break danke an
dich markus oder tobias für die
einsendung dieses perfekt und das ist
richtig cool und das könnt ihr einfach
mal selber austesten danke für die
einsendung des nächsten facts anja
nikkei fun fun tnt und zwar geschrieben
hallo kontrast ich habe in der neuen
version 1.8 preis herausgekommen dass
man auf wasser teppiche platzieren kann
indem man ein
ein höher setzt als das wasser und dann
auf einer seite des blockes nicht oben
oder unten dem wasser auf das teppich
setzt den teppich auf das wasser nicht
den wasser auf das teppich setzen kann
und zwar seht ihr schon so wenn ich hier
mache denke erst mal hürde gilt adiga
league draufsetzen das ist aber einfach
nur weil wasser hier nicht als plot kann
wird auf der mars draufsetzen kann das
geht nur bei diesen libyen auf diesem
wasser rosen teilen und zwar kann ich ja
hier ganz normalen teppich draufsetzen
und dann kann ich ja hier wird der
teppich als block angesehen dann kann
ich ja auch einfach teppiche dran setzen
und das aller coole daran ist bei schnee
funktioniert das ganze glaube ich nicht
allerdings wird das hier so wirklich als
block anerkannt das heißt wenn ich hier
gegen fliege werde ich total gestoppt
hier wird das jetzt auch noch mal wenn
ich jetzt ruhiger laufen und zwar kann
man hier richtig coole wege direkt über
das wasser machen einfach aus teppichen
das heißt ich kann hier beispielsweise
auch ich weiß nicht ob es noch hellere
teppich ich glaube es gibt noch den hier
der ähnelt dem wasser glaube ich noch
mehr so ich mache mal eben so das sieht
richtig gut aus und zwar kann man damit
einfach so wege über das wasser quasi
erstellen und es sieht nicht mal
irgendwie umwelt zerstört oder oder auch
in grün kann man dass er theoretisch
auch machen wegen dem gras dann hat das
mit dem gras dass sie vielleicht sogar
noch besser aus und dann kann man hier
richtig coole wege über das wasser
erstellen und ich glaube sogar beide
farben passen das grün passt zum gras
und es blau passte zum wasser und dann
kann man damit richtig richtig coole
wege erstellen direkt über das wasser
und das ganze funktioniert doch als man
kann darüber laufen und mit diesem
kleinen trick dass man beispielsweise
hier ist was hinsetzt und dann da dann
kann man da einfach teppiche über das
wasser platzieren und somit
beispielsweise ein sprungturm machen u
und ja ich würde noch sagen das war es
dann mit der neuen minecraft packs folge
ich hoffe euch hat dieses 1.8 special
gefallen also was ein 1.8 dazu gekommen
ist wenn ihr auch also ich werde die
zukünftigen folgen alle immer eine 1.8
andrehen
weil bei der nächsten folge
wahrscheinlich die vollversion strauß
ist hoffe ich mal und ich würde einfach
sagen wenn ihr weitere facts abschreibt
per mail an konkreter gmail.com mit dem
betreff irgendwie minecraft 1.8 zeigt
oder minecraft factoring gebracht bitte
nur dinge die ihr noch nicht bei anderen
leuten wie gesehen aber dass es
langweilig wenn ich dann dinge zeige die
eventuell woanders gesehen habe sonst
würde ich sagen wenn ich die serie
gefällt und ihr das ganze feier dann
zeigt mit einem daumen nach oben
und ich würde sagen die umfragen steht
in der beschreibung und was haltet ihr
eigentlich davon wenn ich in der
nächsten folge x 56 mache weil 14
bezahl und ich hätte jetzt
beispielsweise auch noch so viel mehr
wächst die ich euch einfach noch zeigen
möchte und so viele mails geh doch
einfach unter dann mache ich einfach 56
ist dann ein fact mehr oder weniger
zählen mal gucken und er zeigt mir
einfach durch einen daumen nach oben und
bei einer gewissen anzahl keine ahnung
zeigt es mir einfach alles die umfrage
täter beschreiben ich habe total
muskelkater und geld direkt wieder pen
gute nacht